- Why is it so hard to be on time?
Like, why does five to 10
always become 20 to 30?
(jazzy piano music)
If my dab is on fleek, am I lit?
- Why is it a problem if I like anime?
- Why do black people look at your shoes
before they greet you?
- Why are we more likely to
engage in the new dance trend
than we are to get involved in politics
or opening a business?
- How did watermelon become our thing?
Like, everybody should love watermelon.
- Why do you get upset when I
don't like a black celebrity?
- Race aside, some
people are just terrible.
- Why do we call each other the n-word,
but get vehemently upset
when a white person
uses the n-word?
- It drains my soul to hear the word,
and I just don't understand
how people who have
any understanding of
history can use that word.
(upbeat drum and horn music)
- Why is my natural hair,
the hair that grows out of my head,
seen as a political statement?
- Why do we think people
with light skin look better
than people with dark skin?
- Do you really believe
that black is beautiful?
- Or is that just something
you say 'cause it sounds cool?
- Why do some black people
say that you're pretty
for a dark-skinned girl?
- When that is said to me,
it still makes me feel like
the ugliest little black thing.
- Why do some black men
only date white women?
- Why is it okay for black
men to date white women
but not okay for a black woman
to date outside her race?
(rhythmic drum music)
- Why do you protest black lives matter–
- And then tear each other
down in the next breath?
- Why do we say that we don't
want to be seen as a monolith,
but then try to take
people's black cards away
for not liking something
that's supposedly black?
- Why are we so quick to support
a non-black-owned business
but then hesitate when it's
a black-owned business?
- I mean, is there a cutoff
time for this whole homophobia
thing in the black community?
'Cause I'm really looking forward to that.
- Why is growing up without a
father so common in our race?
- Why don't we like to confront
our mental health issues?
Therapy is such a wonderful
and magical place.
(rhythmic clapping music)
- Why is there a
checklist for being black?
- Why is being educated
considered a white thing?
Why can't I love school and also be black?
- Why do I have to be mixed
in order to have long hair?
- Why do you think well-off
black people don't know
what it means to be black?
- Black isn't only defined by adversity.
- Why do some black people say,
oh I have Native American in my family,
in order to feel
interesting or more valuable
than other black people around them?
- Why can't we just
acknowledge that there are
a bunch of different types of
black people walking around,
and they're all amazing
and unique and special
in their own way?
- We, within the black
community, are so quick to
kind of tear each other down
and to look towards other races
in terms of their success and
in terms of what they have,
but never want to kind of look
into the mirror ourselves?
- I love black folks,
but that doesn't mean
I don't have questions.
- Why are we always
looking for the discount?
Shoot, I ain't gonna lie,
I'll be looking at the discount, too.
I don't even know why I'm saying
this, but I'm one of them.